c'est la capitale comme on la voit
jamais l'ordre de confinement est en
vigueur depuis lundi pour les 20
millions d'habitants de moscou et toutes
ses banlieues et cette fois c'est du
sérieux dû faire ça dès le début les
pleurs cette femme au lieu de laisser
les gens se faire des barbecues dans
l'époque une référence à ces images de
moscovites qui ont profité des vacances
payées décrété par le président poutine
pour se réunir au lieu de rester à la
maison alors que le virus se propage et
parmi les nouveaux infectés
il y à l'autre que le médecin en chef du
mégahôpital kommunalka qui traitent les
patients contaminés
dennis protsenko en a fait l'annoncé sur
sa page facebook
le voici avec vladimir poutine pas plus
tard que la semaine dernière alors qu'il
lui offrait une visite des nuits à la
télévision russe était aussitôt la
consternation
tout le monde est à risque le maire le
président et qui va nous sauver de ce
virus a déclaré l'animateur
le kremlin s'est empressé d'annoncer que
poutine va bien et qu'il subit des tests
régulièrement les présidents qu'on voit
peu depuis des semaines semble avoir
complètement sous-estimé la menace de
contagion communautaire et ce malgré
tous les avertissements
car moscou est désormais l'épicentre de
l'épidémie en russie avec des centaines
de nouveaux cas au quotidien dit le
journaliste denniston cove
il s'inquiète surtout pour les régions
démunies d'équipement et d'hôpitaux de
qualité pour le moment dit il personne
ne sait ce qui s'y passe vraiment
d'où l'importance d'interdire aux
moscovites de bouger et d'envahir des
régions telles que celle de ceux qui
marquent à tourcoing
écoute moi comme cette jeune femme l'a
fait elle dit avoir fui la grisaille de
la capitale où tout le monde panique et
portent des masques
le genre de comportement qui sera
dorénavant punis car il semble que seuls
les sanctions convaincre les gens de
suivre les consignes dit pavel un
étudiant à moscou kenny [ __ ] et de la
douma ont d'ailleurs approuvé d'urgence
des punitions majeures dont sept ans de
prison pour une personne qui causerait
la mort d'un concitoyen les autorités
pourraient aussi sous peu distribué un
code barre à chaque résident afin de
contrôler leurs déplacements
le jour comme la nuit ici tamara alter
escaut radio canada
mon frère